madame mademoiselle monsieur bonjour
bienvenue sur le plateau d' autrement
dit c'est un plateau en fait aujourd'hui
que j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter
oui le cinéma à 100 ans vous savez ça
depuis quelques temps mais savez vous
que c'est précisément dans cette ville
de lyon car sentant jour pour jour jour
pour jour on va voir avec bertrand
tavernier on ne sait pas très bien mais
on va faire seuls 19 mars et le 19 mars
1895 et bien les frères lumière ont posé
leurs petites boîtes en bois et ils ont
filmé la sortie de leur usine et c'est
le premier film c'est l'histoire
prestigieuse de toute la magie du 20e
siècle a commencé ce jour là alors
bertrand tavernier vous êtes notre
invité à plusieurs titres aujourd'hui
bien sûr d'abord pour ça pour le
centenaire
parce que vous en attendez grand
organisateur en tant que président de
l'institut lumière
mais si vous propose ma une interview
avec trois images et une surprise si
vous voulez bien pour essayer de faire
tout puisque sa première fois aussi con
que je ne le plaisir de vous recevoir
dans cette émission alors on va on va
faire on va faire un complet si vous
voulez bien je vous propose une première
image pour parler de bertrand tavernier
peut-être un petit peu plus intime
on se retourne vers le regard intérieur
et l'immeuble ne doit pas donner
l'apparence d'une maison cossue l'entrée
de l'appartement de doit lui même pas
donné l'idée de des somptuosité que va
re que va montrer l'appartement qu'il
montrera du reste très peu d'étrangers
puisqu'on habite pas les étrangers soit
sauf de très rares exceptions mais il
convient donc ne pas éveiller la
jalousie la suspicion des autres
personnes dans leur bus montrant des
apparences qui soit par troy par trop
fastueux c'est le contraire du parisien
qui ont vu
tu es lyon revêt des formes
particulières recevoir des amis ou des
parents chez soi c'est évidemment
toujours un peu plus complexe dès lors
que chacun possède une clé de son
immeuble et naturellement c'est très
l'immeuble n'appartient pas ni aux amis
de passage ni même vos amis qui devaient
rouault parents qui demeurent dans la
ville dont elle savait qu'ils allaient
c'est la clé la fameuse clé dalé qui
permet de s'introduire non pas dans
l'appartement mais dans l'allée qui
précède l'appartement dans lequel on
trouvera l'odeur exquise qui précède la
loge de la concierge 7
ces remugles mélanger urines de soupe
aux choux le cervelas et qui donne à
l'entrée de l'immeuble de tout de suite
quelque chose de particulier cette clé
d'aller ils étaient les dispositions
seulement la famille qui habite
l'appartement n'est pas conséquent
lorsque l'on reçoit tout est de préparer
minutieusement telle avance et lorsqu'on
n'a pas d'essence heures on descend
jusqu'en bas pour ouvrir la porte celui
qui doit rentrer fasse un petit quand
même un peu disparu de sa cité de
internet access paru c'est très très
regrettable parce que leur n'importe qui
peut venir n'importe quand je vais vous
bien bertrand tavernier c'est donc un
extrait du regard intérieur c'est le
film que vous avez fait sur lyon
d'ailleurs ici avec les équipes de
france 3 oui oui mais là bon on viens de
voir on vient de voir quelque chose qui
vous tient très à coeur trait au fond de
vous même parce que c'est bertand
dernier face à son père oui c'est mon
père qui me parlait de lyon 2-2 de sa
jeunesse la description de certains
caractères camsa de caractéristiques
actuelles lyonnaises qui ont peut-être
disparu enfin parce que c'est vrai qu'il
est maintenant il ya des codes la clé
d'aller été remplacé par les codes mais
je me demandais ce que cet état d'esprit
a tout à fait disparu je ne je ne je ne
sais pas je ne sais pas et je trouve que
mon père en parlait parlait avec une
ironie et une tendresse tout à fait
formidable ce que je voulais montrer
travers ce film c'est que pour moi mon
père c'était un peu l'image de lyon
c'était qu'il en avait la lyre owni la
culture le côté secret c'est quelqu'un
avec lequel j'ai eu
j'ai peut-être pas eu assez de rapports
j'ai eu du mal à s y avoir des rapports
parce qu'il ne se livrait pas sinon de
manière un peu
un peu drôle et il en avait les rues
dition il y avait tous côtés et la
curiosité des choses qui sont très
importantes je crois qu'en qui sont qui
appartiennent à l'image de lyon alors la
question que vous avez osé cent fois
donc vous êtes lyonnais ce que vous vous
sentez lyonnaise toujours revendiqué
comme tel je me revendique cinéaste
lyonnais même quand je tourne pas à lyon
je pense que j'essaye de mettre dans
dans dans mes films des jeux c'est pas
des éléments lyonnaise y sont d'ailleurs
malgré moi le goût du secret la
recherche de certaines lumières et c'est
en tournant ce film que je m'étais
aperçu que très souvent dans les décors
en fait je recherchais des décors des
appartements une lumière qui avaient des
salles de mon enfance je recherchais ça
dans toutes les villes que ce soit
glasgow que ce soit à paris où j'ai
beaucoup de mal à les trouver
je recherche ça est un film comme un
dimanche à la campagne et nourri de
chose de lyon ii d'expression que
j'entendais dans ma famille un sucre ou
pas du tout par exemple du tout à fait
le lyonnais est dans le dimanche à la
campagne vous aviez même retrouvé des
tableaux de peintres
j'avais mis des grâces a cherché un
grâce à monsieur bosse il ya les
galeries le lutrin qui est un qui a des
tableaux formidable parce qu'il ya des
peintres lyonnais en plus de magnifiques
qui sont d'ailleurs sous-estimé jeu
totalement supprimé je pense à combes et
des combes qui est un pâtre admirable et
qu'à paris on ne connaît pas alors on
est rentrés vraiment dans le vif du
sujet on va pas faire de psychanalyse la
petite semaine les bons rené tavernier
votre père qui a été le grand poète
qu'on connaît le grand homme si je
dirais de courage que l'on n'a pas
oublié vous évoquez vos relations un peu
difficile avec lui d'ailleurs le film
avait été presque un peu à un moment de
réconciliation ou même pas de
réconciliation n'est toujours été proche
mais disons qu'on ce navet du mal à
parler de deux choses intimes ce qui est
peut-être une chose lyonnaise est une
sorte de pudeur du sentiment moi je
trouve en angleterre est a lyon je
trouve une sorte de chasser béraud qui
dit que
henri béraud que lyon est la ville des
sentiments secrets d amour fidèle je
trouve que c'est une belle définition et
c'est vrai que en plus mon père était
quelqu'un de tellement cultiver de
tellement drôle que je pouvais avoir des
conversations magnifique avec lui mais
est ce qu on se parlait de choses très
très très intime je ne sais pas je ne
sais pas est-ce que c'est difficile
d'être le fils de quelqu'un qui a déjà
justement une grande surface qui s'est
déjà illustré dans l'écriture il fallait
vous démarquer il fallait faire autre
chose
je pense qu'il faudrait demander ça mon
fils c'est par hasard qu'il ya un qui a
eu du mal à trouver à exister que
maintenant existe formidablement
formidablement et j'en suis très très
très très fier en tant que comédien et
en tant que auteur de documentaires qui
sont des documentaires je trouve
magnifique magnifique et oui j'ai eu je
pense que j'ai eu du mal et que j'ai je
pense que c'est pas un hasard si j'ai
choisi alors que j'avais un père qui
était féru de littérature de poésie de
livres ce que j'ai été aussi car j'ai
dévoré et je lui en serai toujours
reconnaissant de m'avoir appris la
curiosité et la passion mais il était
féru de lives et de musique classique
puisqu'il jouait même du violon moi j'ai
choisi le cinéma et le jazz
j'ai choisi l'image et le jazz je pense
en au début on le décevant un petit peu
il me voyait aller du côté de de
sciences po et de l'ena et moi je
n'étais pas du tout ça que je que dont
j'avais envie 20 ans à quelque chose
près après votre premier film
enfin le premier l'horloger de saint
paul en 1964 dans le premier film
vous venez de frapper si je puis dire un
gros coup c'est lé deuxième image qu'on
regarde ce matin voici la bande de la
bande annonce que vous avez monté
vous-même de l'apa mois ci
avez vous déjà fait l'amour qu'on n'a
pas changé rattaché au téléphone il ya
10% qu'il en fait trop
pour réussir il faut penser grand
l'amérique n'est pas l'hexagone je crois
que tu es trouver quelqu'un je vais te
le présenter
et toi et fais ici battant qu'est ce que
tu cherches là je joue tout fait en tête
figure toi oui michael sabia savoir
lesquels j'attends le match tambour
battant
françois dupré avocat me rend triste
producteurs invoquent à wahaha avait
fauché tout ça à mon nom petite virée
chez ea nous l'amérique
alors la croche choeur à l'ordre
on donne des faux numéro
bon c'est vachement et 3 s'être classés
tels 4 comment ça c'est pas bon il ya
des caméras partout il ya un pas qui va
débarquer
et
[Musique]
walfoot contre bagnols une maison saint
tropez enchaîné à megève et des bureaux
lancé diane et fatima
[Musique]
saadi tous ces trucs là c'est à nous
c'est juste pour voir faire
la vente à vernier nous sommes vous et
moi de la génération des parents de ces
jeunes gens que vous venez de faire
vivre au cinéma la passe et sur tous les
écrans actuellement je rappelle que vous
venez d'avoir une merveilleuse
récompense qui l'ours d'or à berlin pour
ce film là il y avait bien longtemps que
film français avec un réalisateur
français n'avait pas eu de récompense
dans ce grand festival je disais ces
jeunes gens cette génération là c'est un
film terrible que vous avez fait vous
avez voulu faire un film terrible je ne
sais pas si j'ai j'ai pensé exactement
ces termes j'ai voulu un peu oui
secoué secouer un peu les choses comme
on dit je les guide plusieurs fois au
québec
à propos de l 627 il me disait je vois
là un film formidable c'est un film qui
place la cage brasser la cage je trouve
c'est une magnifique expression on se
rappelle ça c'est un film sur la drogue
oui l 627 était sur la police sur la
drogue et j'ai voulu faire un film alors
de l'autre côté
non pas sur les gens qui sont chargés de
faire respecter la loi une loi dont
personne que personne n'allait à prendre
au sérieux qui n'a pas l'air de on se
décharge sur sur quelques flics d'un
groupe stups bourg pour finalement
palier je pense une grande démission
collective et là j'ai voulu prendre
l'autre côté de prendre des gens qui
déjeunent qui sont sympathiques touchant
drôle par moment et qui vont dérivés
presque ordinaire ah oui si c'est oui
c'est mes enfants c'est les copains de
mes enfants ça peut être ça peut être
les vôtres ça peut être ce n'importe qui
et et j'ai envie que j'ai envie qu'il
soit proche de du public
j'ai voulu les rendre proche et vous lui
c'est pas des gens où il ya marqué ils
ont raison pas un pin's avec épinglettes
excusez moi
avec le mot délinquants marqué dessus et
pourtant et pourtant ils vont sombrer
dans une délinquance horrible oui oui
qu'on le voit pas attention et je veux
dire on voit pas touchés je trouve que
quand on si on veut parler de la
violence il faut pas il faut pas la
montrer il faut pas la banaliser
il faut là et là moi j'avais la chance
d'avoir des acteurs formidables et
d'avoir marie gillain qu'on peut voir
dans une france qui était hier soir et
elle elle est resplendissante
adressez-vous sais mais c'est un bonheur
c'est que cette marie c'est quelqu'un de
sublimes sublime sublime et c'était beau
de la voir de voir l' effort est dur de
voir la violence dans ses yeux
dans ses yeux alors ces jeunes gens la
différence de votre jeunesse que vous
avez bloqué et qu'il ya quelques mini
jeux vous disiez manger dévorer des
livres saints manifestement ils n'ont
pas eu grand chose
oui c'est une partie rené le film ne dis
pas que c'est la jeunesse
il ya des traits je pense de ces
personnages qu'on peut qu'ils sont assez
répandues c'est vrai qu'ils sont des
choses inquiétantes le l'absence de
passion de curiosité moi je me mettrais
très en colère quand je j'ai j'ai
affaire à des classes et que des gens
vous disent ah ben on peut pas voir un
vieux film où on venait on n'est pas
capable de voir un film français ça vous
prend la tête
c'est ça vous prend la tête alors j'ai
essayé de faire un film qui en même
temps leur parle qui soit rapide nerveux
drôles cocasses et en même temps qu'il
est kylie kylie qui remettent en
question le et puis les adultes tout
autour mais c'est vrai qu'à une forme
d'ignorance qui me met terriblement en
colère et surtout un manque de passion
l'impression qu' il faut on ne participe
pas on ne participe plus ont subi et
subit les images ont subi les images ont
subi la dictature de l'argent oui du
pognon de la publicité qui vous un
pauvre les valeurs oui des choses comme
ça des valeurs qu'ils sont
joueur absolument dérisoires vous savez
quand j'étais quand on allait par
exemple avec certains des acteurs de l
627 avec mon fils avec nils avec
charlotte kady qui va être là pour
célébrer le centenaire qui est une
actrice lyonnaise avec laraque guirao
qu'on allait présenter l 627 très
souvent les mômes
il connaissait tous les les pubs qui
avait fait charlotte kady 1,7 et les
pubs et leur question c'est combien tu
gagnes quand tu fais un film combien tu
gagnes combien étaient payés ont été
payés c'est pas qu'est ce que c'est
d'être actrice comment tu es bien où tu
n'es pas bien c'était l'argent qui est
ça je trouvais ça je trouve ça terrible
de même que très souvent une des
questions cons qu'on vous pose c'est
quel est le budget d'un film parce que
en plus ça fait partie d'une chose que
j'aie de dénoncer aussi dans le film
c'est celle à la fosse connaissance on
croit qu'on contrôle la vie parce qu'on
manipule des sommes d'argent comme ça en
chiffres une chose qui vous inquiète ces
six jeunes gens chez ces jeunes gens
c'est leur impatience
oui oui c'est celle un peu l'impression
que ils ont tellement avalé dion la
notion de zapping la notion que quand il
ya un truc un tout petit peu embêtant
hop on passe sur autre chose
sur une autre image on fait pas l'effort
de regarder qui veulent la paix dans la
vie hein mais c'est dur de zapper dans
la vie c'est dur de et donc on compte
c'est comme s'il ne contrôlait pas la
minute qui vont vivre
est ce assez c'est ce que je voulais
montrer c'est ce qui explique leur
dérapage n'est pas des gens qui partent
pour faire la violence mais petit à
petit c'est comme si la violence leur
échapper il aurait échappé et sachez ce
que je sais ce que je voulais montrer
c'était quelque chose de pour moi je
trouve de très patient de très important
de très important parce que je reçois
constamment depuis que le film est sorti
des témoignages d'éducateurs de profs de
de gens là une lettre que je vous ai
montré
j'ai reçu sur un fait divers lyonnais
sont atteints ce matin on m'a apporté
sur quelqu'un qui a été
et à coup de fusil à pompe parce que des
parents conservent des armes n'ose rien
dire parce que c'est une honte on laisse
on laisse et que et que cette possession
d'armes
c'est comme la possession des des
montres et des stylos dans mon film
c'est pour exister on n'existera peut
être parce qu'on a un fusil à pompe on
n'existera parce que on a une montre ou
un stylo d'une certaine pas parce que on
fait quelque chose et ça moi sic
moi j'appartiens à une génération où on
apprenait qu'on existait parce qu'on
faisait et qu'on était responsable père
m'a toujours dit m'a toujours parlé de
la notion de responsabilité on est
responsable de ses actes en vie dans un
pays on a l'impression que
l'irresponsabilité cultiver ou au
maximum on en a des preuves dans la
politique continuellement on en a eu des
preuves dans l'histoire du sang
contaminé
on en a des preuves dans les deux procès
de bernard tapie à l'heure actuelle on
voit un ministre finalement six essais
ce qui est ce qui est passé de faire un
faux témoignage quand on est quand même
un homme d'état c'est une responsabilité
morale effrayante effrayante
alors c'est vrai que cette notion
peut-être qu'elle est assimilée
peut-être que devant ce flou
d'irresponsabilité qui arrive tout
autour eh bien les je crois que c'est un
virus
je crois que c'est un virus les
responsabilités l'inconscience et c est
ça se communique sa ce comique quand
cela vient du président de la république
en premier lieu et que c'est après vous
trouvez dans le ministre d'intérieur
vous trouvez dans un très grand nombre
de personnes qui sont mis en examen à
l'heure actuelle je pense que c'est une
maladie et c'est un virus comme le sida
c'est un virus et et c'est ce que je
voulais un petit peu montrés dans le
film
bertrand tavernier la dernière question
sur ce film qu'on voulait se pose mais
bien souvent je vais je faire comme tout
le monde
comment vous faites avec votre
scénariste pour être aussi juste pour
être aussi proche de ces gens on a
l'impression qu'on les a rencontrés la
veille qu'ils ont les mêmes répliques
j'hallucine j'hallucine il ya pas mal de
jeunes qui veulent opposer en disant
notamment
oui c'est un film on se retrouve
complètement dans les dialogues dans la
façon de bouger de
exister comme un type de votre âge y
arrive et et arrive à être aussi juste
et à chaque fois je reçois un coup sur
la tête terrible je prends de 30 ans
j'ai pas de réponse je sais que kolo
tavernier moi même on est on essaie
d'être curieux on écoute on on reste en
contact avec la vie moi je dis qu'une
des grandes choses s'est pas avoir de
voiture déjà un
ça m'oblige à marcher continuellement à
regarder les choses dans la rue je fais
que marché et et c'est sûr que je j'ai
l'impression d'être d'être vraiment en
contact je prends le métro l'autobus je
suis à l'afp j'écoute tout le temps tout
le temps tout le temps alors maintenant
monsieur le président on a situé les
venons en donc on va regarder un film
dont on n'a jamais aussi jamais posé la
question vous faites sur son budget
celui ci allait regardons là on regarde
on est comme en temps parce que c'est
des images les voilà les voilà les deux
ouvrières qu est alors alors c'est là
qu'elle version sommes en jeu c'est la
mienne c'est la bonne
enfin on ne sait pas on ne sait pas on
ne sait pas combien une vertu et on ne
sait pas finalement est-ce que ça a été
répétée ou pas parce que quand je vois
qu'il ya un chien quand je vois que yann
la voiture à cheval est arrivé le tout
ça il fallait que ça sorte en 50
secondes
comment est ce qui pouvait en être sûr
ça allait sortir en 50 secondes quand on
sait les blés problème qu'il y avait un
type à bicyclette ya bien donc je me
demandais ce que ça a été répété moi je
mens je pense que c'est un film
complètement mise en scène
d'abord on le verra dimanche s'était
tourné à midi pour une soirée la lumière
oui à cause de la lumière donc c'est une
fausse sortie commentée au t1 qui
souvent au théâtre d'une fausse sortie
mais il ya beaucoup d'autres questions
qui se posent c'est est ce que les
ouvrières étaient prévenus forcément
donc est-ce qu'elle s'habillait
différemment parce qu'elle savait
qu'elle allait de photographier et
comment ce qu'ont les prévenait est ce
qu'il y avait quelqu'un à l'intérieur de
l'usiné qui poussait qui disaient aller
plus vite
est ce qu'il y avait un assistant pour
régler ça
je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de questions
moi qui me qui me qui m'amuse par
rapport au même mois se à ce tournage
alors ce tournage là donc on l'adapté à
peu près du 19 mars
oui ce qu' il a été en tout cas le film
a été projeté à paris le 22 mars donc il
a dû être tourné quelques jours
auparavant oui oui oui d'après le
bernard chardère fait des études sans
jamais this year sur la météo sur la
météo et trouve que donc et c'est vrai
que là on est en train de regarder le
ciel la météo et le est à la fois le
compagnon est l'ennemi du metteur en
scène à chaque fois c'est l' angoisse la
plus terrible surtout les tournages des
cons et en extérieur
d'ailleurs qu'un film comme un dimanche
à la campagne la météo n'était heure par
heure film dirais même minute par minute
en liaison avec la météo de 2,2 des
aéroports et est en effet tu sais on
pense que c'est le que c'est le 19 mars
est ce qu'on va célébrer demain et nous
on en avait envie de célébrer le
tournage la création le moment où
quelqu'un n'a pas dit moteur parce qu'on
ne disait pas un moteur qui achètent et
parce qu'il a dit je ne sais pas allez
sortez close et allons-y à l'ailé petit
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas mais de
célébrer ce moment où un personnage ou
doudou ou quelqu'un a mis la caméra dans
une rue et a eu l'idée de créer le
premier personnage de l'histoire du
cinéma qui est la foule et c'est
intéressant de voir que le premier héros
du premier film c'est le peuple et c'est
la foule ça vous plaît énormément ça me
plait énormément je trouve que c'est une
toujours une idée intéressante
je pense que le signe le cinéma européen
toujours été plus attachés à la
collectivité que le cinéma américain qui
a toujours été plus individualiste gris
marron dans les premiers films de edison
c'est un jeu c'est un chien ou un chien
un chat boxeur j'en ai déjà dans
l'individualisme
frères lumière c'est la foule qu'on
retrouvera dans nombreux frime dans de
nombreux films comme le l'entrée
l'entrée du train dans la gare de la
ciotat alors bertrand tavernier
reparlons de lyon à propos du cinéma
comme lui comment se fait-il que cette
ville est et si longtemps oublié qu'elle
était quelque part la capitale
fondatrice du cinéma comment se fait-il
que il ait fallu tant d'efforts et vous
vous le savez bien et c'est pas
aujourd'hui évidemment vous allez me
dire à personne nous a aidés mais quand
même quand même qu est ce qu on a mis
deux c'est vrai qu'en cinq ans cinq six
ans il ya eu un effort énorme qu'il a
essayé de rattraper le temps perdu il
n'avait pas été fait avant et c'est vrai
que la nouvelle municipalité nous a
beaucoup aidés et nous a soutenus et
c'est vrai que c'est un effort qui
aurait dû être fait depuis depuis depuis
50 ans bah oui parce qu'on n'aurait
peut-être pas aujourd'hui simplement un
fantôme de hangars un peu oui on
n'aurait pas on aurait la deuxième
maison
oui il y aurait la maison des frères
lumière des frais y aura un certain
nombre de choses qui auraient été il y
aurait eu un monument véritablement fait
par la ville et non pas dû à la
générosité de d'un amateur qui skie qui
est qui et qui aura été érigé pour les
pour les frères lumière et puis je sais
pas en moi je une des premières choses
qu'on a demandé bernard chardère je
crois dans un conseil d'administration
c'est qu'on met lyon berceau du
cinématographe capitale du
cinématographe
il ya un certain nombre de villes qui
celle qui célèbre nip niépce le ccdh est
célébrée il est célébré et les frères
lumière ne le sont pas c'est dans le
procès verbal du premier conseil
d'administration en 80 jusqu'au 86e
bon oui mais maintenant oui 13 14 ans on
va peut-être que finalement on arrivera
un jour
vous savez je pense que tous les gens
qui ont essayé de faire des arts d'idées
des à lyon ont eu du mal on se souvient
des démêlés terrible de planchon de
maréchal de nombreux metteurs en scène
de théâtre
ils ont souvent un certain nombre de
problèmes à lyon mon père avec
confluence si elle n'avait pas mon père
me disait toujours que à lyon on aimait
l'art de la représentation c'est à dire
la musique est considéré comme quelque
chose de noble qu'on étudiait très très
très très bien mais que les hardis des
lézards qui parlait du mans 2-2 de la
réalité qui pouvait être le théâtre le
les rôles et les romans et regardez même
certains auteurs que me gabriel
chevallier ne sont pas du tout du tout
du tout célébré à lyon or il a écrit une
quinzaine de livres formidable
avouez que si les lumières s'était
trouvé dans n'importe quelle ville
anglaise américaine a gelé 10 des
centaines de fois que si c'était à plélo
is light
il aurait il y aurait des cars de
touristes allaient le japonais viendrait
il y aurait le premier décor du premier
film de l'histoire du cinéma les
américains auraient construit disneyland
autour et oui il nous pendant une époque
il fallait que se battre pour qui est
pas un projet immobilier qui détruisent
la barque avec quand mon bernat fallait
qu'on se bat avec la mairie de lyon là
dessus et en août expliqué mais certes
syrien sais rien je ne sais pas j'ai
jamais très bien compris pourquoi cette
il y avait cette hostilité il y avait
cet ostracisme
est ce que comme le dit mon père c'est
parce que c'est une vieille idée reste
une tradition lyonnaise qui dit que si
on fait un peu trop de publicité on va
faire venir des gens d'ailleurs et
des étrangers qui sont pas d'ici qui
viendront voir d'un coup d'un musée il y
avait aussi ça dans un must dans
certains musées lyonnais mon bras on m'a
raconté des histoires formidables de
conservatrice qui disait qu'il ne
fallait pas que trop de visiteurs parce
que ça pouvait rayer le parquet donc on
encourageait on empêchait plutôt les
visiteurs devenir un des plus grand
musée de peinture de 2,2 de france
s'allumant bertrand tavernier j'ai une
petite surprise maintenant nous avons
entrepris ici la france 3 lyon et c'est
un réalisateur qui s'appelle qu est un
petit sac de filmer sans rêve de cinéma
et on a pris des jeunes gens et on leur
a demandé
dites-moi rêve de cinéma ça dure une
minute je vous en ai sélectionné un pour
vous voici un rêve de cinéma
séduits geffard st c'est quoi ton d un
si j'étais le mec qui se passe tous âges
était le mec qui je puisse vous avez vu
dans pulp fiction mais qui se fait jeter
par la fenêtre parce qu'il à masser les
pieds de l'art la femme du patron alors
ils passent par fenêtre c'était un très
douloureux
enfin non non c'est pas du tout ça ah
ben si j'étais bambi lessa mer à nourrir
ça c'est triste je pleurais enfin non je
dis bon mais quand c'est pas ça c'est
les rambo racheter en bout parce que nés
tués sa copine a rejeté tapis dans mon
prêt à surgir pour me venger mois que
j'étais actes non j'étais le prenant
leçon l'assistant du preneur de son du
film
la ruée vers l'or chaplin non je devrais
être acteur réalisateur
enfin bon
j'ai pu enfin bon j'ai fait un rêve soit
cinéma c'était beau c'était très grand
et c'était éternel formidable d'être
aussi la magnifique magnifique
il résume toute l'histoire du cinéma
doudeville l'oubli climat français mais
à part ça c'est très très bien là alors
je pense qu'il en aura 99 autres comme
ça il y en a déjà on va en voir toute la
famille dit d'ailleurs sur notre antenne
et vous demain vous invitez alors les
lyonnais oui et reçoit pour revenir à ce
que disait mais aussi des autres il ya
un grand nombre de metteurs en scène un
peu du monde entier qui viennent et ceux
qui n'ont pas pu venir nous envoyer
d'aider des messages d des télégrammes
des trucs formidables qui veut on a des
messages magnifique de spielberg de
scorsese de fred zinnemann de gens du
but du monde entier du monde entier et
puis il y a on a le plaisir de voir des
gens ça va de claude sautet andré de
tosse de d'un metteur en scène italien
qui à 101 ans
un carlo ludovic obraniak qui donc à vue
a vu naître pratiquement le sénégal le
le cinéma etc a fait des films qu'on
redécouvre dans les années 40
une comédie italienne qui annonce la
rose pourpre du caire était paraît-il
étourdissante étourdissante d'invention
et deux aides et 2 d'invention de mise
en scène et drôlerie on a des gens comme
jerry schatzberg comme claude miller
comme claude lanzmann comme christine
pascal donc il ya comme bernal scène qui
vient d un de carlos dieguez qui vient
du brésil pour nous comme ça on va
réunir ses metteurs en scènes du monde
entier pour célébrer ce moment
formidable qui a fait naître tellement
de rêve
merci bertrand tavernier alors demain
vous pouvez y aller demain et c'est
ouvert c'est libre c'est dans toute la
périphérie du château d'humières il ya
plein d'endroits
allez-y ça comment je crois me dit un
oui à 11 longueurs et c'est toute la
journée de toutes manières de mme en
attend beaucoup de monde
et puis france 3 est bien tout l'après
midi on va fêter le cinéma ce soir aussi
bien sur le journal de
france 3 lyon sera en direct de
l'institut enfin mais rester cet après
midi il ya plein de surprises qu'on vous
a réservé pour pour marquer ça et puis
livrée au cinéma où vous allez voir la
patte bertrand tavernier le fils le plus
terrible que j'ai vu ces derniers jours
quand on aime la vie on va au cinéma et
nous on vous souhaite un excellent
week-end cinématographique il pleut elle
et allez-y vous avez le temps d'aller au
cinéma et de regarder la télé merci
[Musique]